the purpose of this segment is to give
you a little bit of the bigger picture
we did discuss some inequalities we did
discuss convergence of the sample mean
that's the weak law of large numbers and
we did discuss a particular notion of
convergence of random variables
convergence in probability how far can
we take those topics let's start with
the issue of inequalities here one would
like to obtain bounds and approximations
on tail probabilities that are better
than the mark of an chebyshev
inequalities that we have seen this is
indeed possible for example there is a
so called Chernoff bound that takes the
following form the Chernoff bound tells
us that the probability that the sample
mean is away from the true mean by at
least a where a is a positive number
this probability is bounded above by a
function that falls exponentially with n
and where the exponent depends on the
particular number a that we are
considering but in any case this term in
the exponent is a positive quantity
notice that this is much better much
stronger than what we obtained from the
chebyshev inequality because in the
chebyshev inequality we only obtain an
inequality for this probability that
falls off at the rate of 1 over N so
this Falls much faster and so it tells
us that this probability is indeed much
smaller than what the chebyshev
inequality might predict
however this inequality requires some
additional assumptions on the random
variables involved another type of
approximation on this tail probability
can be obtained through the central
limit theorem which will actually be the
next topic that we will be studying very
loosely speaking the central limit
theorem tells us that the random
variable M sub n which is the sample
mean behaves as if it were a normal
random variable with the mean and the
variance that it should
have we know that this is the mean and
the variance of the sample mean but the
central limit theorem tells us that in
addition to that we can also pretend
that the sample mean is normal and carry
out approximations as if this were a
normal random variable now this
statement that I'm making here is only a
loose statement is not mathematically
completely accurate we will see later a
more accurate statement of the central
limit theorem in a different direction
we can talk about different types of
convergence we did define convergence in
probability but that's not the only
notion of convergence that's relevant to
random variables there's an alternative
notion which is convergence with
probability one here is what it means we
have a single probabilistic experiment
and within that experiment we have a
sequence of random variables and another
random variable and we want to talk
about this random variable convergent to
that random variable what do we mean by
that we consider a typical outcome of
the experiment that is some Omega look
at the values of the random variable Y n
under that particular Omega and look at
that sequence of values the values of
the different random variables under
that particular outcome under that
particular outcome Y also has a certain
numerical value and we're interested in
to whether this convergence takes place
as n goes to infinity now for some
outcomes Omega this will happen for some
it will not happen we will say that we
have convergence with probability one if
this event has probability equal to one
that is there is probability one that is
essential certainty that when an outcome
of the experiment is obtained the
resulting sequence of values of the
round
variables yn will converge to the value
of the random variable Y now this
definition is easy to write down but to
actually understand what it really means
and the ways it is different from
convergence in probability is not so
easy it does take some conceptual effort
and we will not discuss it any further
at this point let me just say that this
is a stronger notion of convergence if
you have convergence with probability 1
you also get convergence in probability
and it turns out that the law of large
numbers also holds under this stronger
notion of convergence that is we have
that the sample mean converges to the
true mean with probability 1 this is the
so-called strong law of large numbers
and because this is a stronger notion of
convergence a more demanding one that's
why this is called the strong law
incidentally at this point you might be
quite uncertain and confused as to what
is really the difference between these
two notions of convergence the
definitions do look different but what
is the real difference this is quite
subtle and it does take quite a bit of
thinking it's not supposed to be
something that is obvious so the purpose
of this discussion is only to point out
this further direction but without at
this point going into it in any depth
finally there is another notion of
convergence in which we are looking at
the distributions of the random
variables involved so we may have a
sequence of random variables each one of
them has a certain distribution
described by a CDF and we can ask the
question does this sequence of CDF
converge to a limiting CDF if that
happens then we say that we have
convergence in distribution and this is
more or less the type of convergence
that shows up when we deal with the
central limit theorem because this is
really a statement about distributions
that the distribution of the sample mean
in some sense starts to approach the
distribution of a normal random variable